giant turtles are among the many sea
creatures for whom coral reefs are a
vital natural habitat but that home is
changing representatives from the
fishing authorities of six Caribbean
nations are on a diving expedition to
investigate the condition of the
region's coral reefs under a cute threat
is the strait between st. Kitts and
Nevis known as the narrows measuring
less than four kilometres wide the small
stretch of water is crossed every day by
fishing boats water taxis cruise ships
and local ferries cherry Constantine and
her colleagues from the Nature
Conservancy want to create marine
managed areas one for fishermen the
other for tourists the fishermen
traditionally they set the pots in the
Narrows but what you find that because
it's the the nursery ground if it is
that the the pots are there and they're
taking the juvenile fish then those
juvenile fish do not get to live to be
old and to be bigger and as scientists
we know that a small fish produces a lot
less egg mil millions of less eggs that
are larger fish and so the longer you
let them grow the more fit more eggs
they can produce and the more you get
out of your fishery
some fishermen are not convinced however
despite fish stocks already being
severely depleted often all they have to
sell our smaller fish that nobody used
to eat their catches are barely enough
to make a living from and many have
already quit the trade well it gets slow
you get to really get slow you get to
real slow yeah that's why we do other
kind of work that you could get a dollar
saint kitts faces a conflict of
interests the island lives off tourism
and hotel operators find the fishermen
and nuisance some cast their nets and
traps right by exclusive hotel beaches a
practice soon to be banned it's a race
against time the plan is for fish to
reproduce in peace again in the
protected zone between st. Kitts and
Nevis and spare turtles the deadly
threat of being caught in fishing nets
you